Servant of God, about to bring you up,
man.
>> Hey, man. Can you hear me?
>> All right. You there, servant of God,
can you hear us?
>> Yep, I'm here. Can you hear me?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, perfect. Yeah. Um, I've never done
this before. I mean, I barely even Most
of my friends are Muslim, so I don't
even really have maybe like one or two
Christian friends, but we never talk
about religion. But uh when it comes to
crucifixion, I don't get why Christians
have such a big problem accepting that
no one died for their sins and that
humans are not inherently sinners in the
way you guys understand. Well, we would
have an issue with that because then if
we would reject that the Messiah would
be the the atonement for our sins, then
you would have to also reject the
continuity with the prophets of the Old
Testament that state that the Messiah
will be uh the the one who takes on our
sins.
>> I don't have enough knowledge about the
Old Testament honestly to say anything.
But from cuz I I also watch our
apologetics. Obviously, you know, I know
Orthodox Muslim, he talks a lot about
sacrifice in the Old Testament, and that
kind of it's it goes against what you
say, but
>> he doesn't know what he's talking about.
I'm going to tell you that now, bro.
>> N you guys need to debate him, bro, cuz
>> we already did, bro.
>> Six guests ago, he was talking about
Husman is not he's not someone that's
his main job is not apologetics. He's
just like a
>> It is his main job.
>> No, it's no, he does like da to lay
people, you know. It's not his main job.
>> Yeah.
>> And Daniel's not like really anything
when it comes to to religion discussion.
>> Well, listen. Do do you think that for a
prophet to be a true prophet, he has to
be in continuity with the previous
prophets?
>> 100%. That's why I believe.
>> So, if we show that the previous
prophets believe that the Messiah would
die for our sins and then Muhammad goes
against that, he can't be a true
prophet.
>> But that's the thing. I don't number one
for me the Old Testament is mostly
unreliable and a lot of your
interpretation the church's
interpretation of the Old Testament is
very different to the interpretation of
the Jews.
>> Well the first of all the issue is is uh
you're saying that um you know these
individuals right in the Old Testament
the Jews right they have a different
interpretation also you're saying that
you know they it's not reliable. The
issue is there's no there's no evidence
of that. There is a lot of evidence.
Actually, I was reading a book like
right now while I was waiting cuz I've
been wait. It's literally all about Old
Testament uh you know corruption.
>> Okay. Can you give me an example?
>> Yeah. What's up?
>> Can you give me an example?
>> Well, I mean it was talking about like
for example differences in the story of
Noah's arc between
uh two different uh I don't know what
they're called, but like two different
versions of the Old Testament.
>> What's the Can you show me that?
>> Let me see. Okay. For example, the
sacred text says that Noah was to take
one pair of each animal or species. And
then in the Yah text, uh God orders him
to take seven males and seven seven
females from each of the pure animal
species and then a single pair from the
impure species.
>> Yeah, you do realize that the Yahwist
text is is a theory text, right?
>> Yeah. Honestly, like Okay, I can't
really debate this. I don't have much
knowledge of the Old Testament. That's
why I'm I'm going to start like learning
all this stuff. But
>> yeah, so that wouldn't be a a good a
good point to use.
>> When you say you're learn you're going
to start learning all this stuff, what
exactly are you striving to learn?
You're try you're striving to learn
arguments against the Bible.
>> No, I mean just the whole academic
analysis even like I've seen academic
arguments against the Quran, but then I
also look at reputations on both sides,
whether it's the Christian side or the
Islamic side. And the reason I'm Muslim
is because whenever there's a reputation
to a Muslim argument or some criticism
of it, the reputations that Muslims
give, it's like nothing, you know, that
you can disagree with. It's
>> So what is what have you heard? I'm I'm
curious then. What What have you heard
that was a solid reputation to the
Islamic dilemma?
>> The Islamic dilemma, you know, even when
I was 10 and I'll read that verse, it
made sense to me because
>> you read what verse, sorry. uh the verse
about, you know, uh confirming uh
looking at confirming what they have
before you.
>> There's a there's a bunch of them. It's
not just one.
>> Yeah. I mean, it talks a lot about the
angel in the Torah. But the problem is
you guys have this understanding that
the is just Matthew, Mark, Luke, John.
And
>> I I believe it's Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John. The New Testament. Um Oh,
yeah. That's that's what I believe it
is.
>> You think the Quranic author is
referring to the letter of Paul? The
letters of Paul. The hadith does
>> which hadith
>> in Sai Bukari well actually multiple a
lot of them but the same narration it
quotes uh first Corinthians chapter 2
verse 9.
>> No the quote man I've never heard that.
>> Never. Let me show you. Let me show you
a baby.
>> I've never heard that.
>> All right.
Let me show you what we have here. All
right. Let me go to Hadith.
Put in Let me put it in like that. There
it is.
>> You guys saying big difference between
this Muslim and radar? Yeah, I'm not a
freaking apologist, bro. Uh, but you
guys should debate dean or orthodox
Muslim.
>> We already did, bro.
>> We already We already did that. Been
there, done that.
>> Yeah, I know. But you got to do more
cuz,
>> bro, more. This man Orthodox Muslim
literally said a rock is a person, dude.
Like, what do you mean? What What more
is there a debate? He said that Yahweh
Jesus is Yahweh in a sense.
>> Like bro,
>> are you got he's arguing that the New
Testament has a framework that argues
that Jesus is Yahweh in a lower sense.
>> If you're Jesus, if you're Yahweh in any
sense, then you're the most high. He
even acknowledged that Jesus is the most
high in a sense in that same debate
trying when he's supposed to be refuting
that Jesus is the most high.
>> Yeah.
>> It's over there.
>> It's either you either are the most high
or you're not. There's no
>> he's saying like for example if you go
on chat GPT and you ask it does the New
Testament framework align mostly with
the Aryan framework the Muslim framework
or the Christian uh modern Christian
framework it's going to say Aryan first
then Muslim and then Christian
>> I don't care
>> no it's not first it's definitely not
going to say Muslim for Christian but
>> it's gonna say
>> first of all it depends on how you're
programming what chat GBT how chat GBT
I don't I couldn't I could care I
couldn't care less Yeah.
>> You have we go through the scriptures.
There's not an ounce of aranism. There's
not an ounce of Islam in the scriptures.
Not one.
>> Yeah.
>> What do you mean, man? John 17:3 is like
>> Okay. Well, we could talk about that in
in a second. We'll talk about that.
>> All right. So, here's uh here's the
hadith sukari 7498. You can see the
screen.
>> Yep.
>> All right. So, first we're going to look
at uh what Paul says over here on the
right. So he says but it but but as it
is written what no eye has seen nor ear
heard nor the heart of man imagined what
God has prepared for those who love him.
>> Yeah. Over here in the hadith narrated
uh Abu Herrera the prophet said Allah
said
>> I have prepared for my righteous saves
slaves as no eye has ever seen nor an
ear has ever heard nor a human heart can
ever think of.
>> Again this is like this why I say you
guys have weak arguments because this is
just first of all we would say this is
in continuity with what Jesus preached
about the you know the kingdom of
heaven. Paul, this is Paul.
>> It is Paul. But Paul might have got it
from Jesus as well.
>> But Paul Jesus never said these words.
He never said this.
>> But how do we know that just by looking
at, you know, Matthew, Mark, Luke, John?
>> He never said this
>> because Jesus could have said a lot that
we don't know about,
>> brother. Jesus never said this. The only
>> the only the only place that we have
this recorded in history is Paul's
letter. You know, I'm pretty sure it's
in other places when it comes
>> when you when you say when you say that.
Look, we're just letting you know
because you said you're just getting
into this. Just so I care about you. I
love you. So, I don't want you to
embarrass yourself in future
conversations. When you say, "I'm pretty
sure that this," then that means that
you have evidence to suggest what you're
saying. Otherwise, you should not say,
"I'm pretty sure." And then
>> okay what I'm arguing is that the idea
of heaven and I would say from the time
of Adam has always been this that it is
something that God has prepared things
for us that we don't even understand.
>> Then why did why does he take the words
verbatim from Paul though to express
this.
>> It's not verbatim. I mean I can see like
the English reads differently.
It's what I what no eye has seen as no
eye has ever seen nor ear heard nor an
ear has ever heard nor the heart of man
imagined nor a human heart can ever
think of what God has prepared what
Allah has prepared for those who love
him.
>> Yeah. But like for example the words
righteous slaves. No there's the
difference. The righteous slaves part is
the difference.
>> Yeah.
>> For those who love it. For those who
love. But like that's what I'm saying.
Like for example, if the Quran says,
"Oh, worship your God alone." And the
Bible says that, are we going to say
it's plagiarizing the Bible?
>> Oh, no. Because we're not talking about
a generic statement that you can find in
any religion. What we're talking about
is an exact quote, an exact reference,
but the exact Hold on. Let me finish,
brother.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> We're talking about the exact quote and
exact reference uniquely found in Paul's
letters. You don't find this in
Hinduism. You don't find this in um you
don't find this in Buddhism. You don't
find this in Islam. You don't find this
in the four accounts of the gospel. Even
when Paul is saying, but as it is
written, it's not even said like this in
the Old Testament where he's quote where
he's uh getting this reference from. He
actually paraphrases the reference and
you know words it this way into which
makes Paul's statement unique. That's
the point. So we know where the where
the hadith is referencing this. It's
from Paul's letter from first
Corinthians.
>> Okay. But look, this is why I would use
it to my strength. For example, uh Jesus
quoted a lot of things, very specific
parables that the prophet also quotes.
>> Say that again.
>> There are a lot of parables that Jesus
uses in in the gospels.
>> Mhm.
>> That the prophet himself, he narrates
very similar uh parables.
>> Okay.
>> But again, I would say that's
>> So that would mean that he gets it these
parables from Jesus then.
>> No, he gets it from God.
>> No, he's getting it from Jesus.
>> Nope. that bro that this what I talk
about when I talk about continuity and
all these like uh you know similar
sayings it's all to do with the same
>> so so this is what I need you to do my
brother I need you to explain the
continuity with Paul and and uh Muhammad
right here
>> like I said Paul could have heard it
from Jesus and we
>> can you give me can All right so when
you when you offer me an explanation an
alternative explanation that means that
you have evidence to suggest what you're
suggesting
>> we don't need evidence
We don't need evidence. This is
>> We don't need evidence. You man, you
They already got you. You're already
ready for the scene. I promise you.
>> You're telling me you need evidence for
this.
>> Servant of God, you are ready for the
Dawa scene. But the second you said
that, you're you're a perfect candidate.
>> Perfect.
>> You You guys realize Christians are very
blind about their faith compared to
>> You literally just say you don't need
evidence.
>> Notice Notice this. You're the Muslim
who just said we don't need evidence and
you're saying we're blind about our
faith.
>> Even if one of your church fathers said
something.
>> Wait, wait, wait. Can you can you
address what I just said? Who's the one
that's blind about our faith? Me. The
one who's bringing evidence suggesting
what I believe
>> or you the one who says we don't need
evidence.
>> Let me clarify. If Jesus tells let's say
>> just really quick, which one of us is
blind, bro?
>> Okay, listen. Listen.
>> Which one of us is blind? The one who
accepts it?
says, "We don't need it."
>> If Jesus tells Bob, "All right, this
that quote you brought up in I'm I'm
going to give you another chance, man,
to be honest and answer."
>> Bob tells Paul and Paul relays it in
Corinthians.
>> Take care of yourself, man.
>> You went straight, Bob Mo. But hey, I
want to I want to give you some
encouragement today, man. You are you
are ready. You're ready.
>> Bring up you're you're absolutely ready
for the Dawa scene. It's it's characters
like you that are dishonest with what's
in front of them, make up any kind of
excuse that they can, and declare
evidence irrelevant. You are the perfect
candidate for the Dawa scene. You'll
blow up, bro. I promise you, you will
blow up. You're next. You're next up,
man. Keep going.
>> Literally,
>> keep going. You You You'll pass me up in
subscribers. I'm telling you. I'm
telling